back at Papa's okay Papa's well back way
out back I'm looking up because I moved
to monitor up there okay it's been a
while let's say here move spaces it's
okay
and we're back to the kingdom Oh lovely
with club Iraq the level fives now club
are okay
the reason taken a while is because it
takes a while for this thing to build up
you only get 40 per day in a max of 240
isn't really much to do much and I like
the video with 200 but also after like
four days I was still busy so anyhow um
hey Charlie ready it's finally ready I
put some spectacles on you know I'm kind
of far away okay
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
where the heck was I last I think I was
in the rats head but I think it was an
ear eye plane yet the battle there we go
so we got to finish this keep searching
for the boss bat I can attack with my
meat staff that's disgusting I can
venture again attack with my maid staff
yes Pat way that way okay holy [ __ ] a
scream bat okay attack with the attack
attack attack attack okay uh I figured I
had to keep on attack Oh she'll open up
okay the bean bat chamber
okay fighting the being bat
it's a beam instead of a body very weird
but I'm going to keep on fighting came
out of hiding madness now I got huh that
was a render and it's here get to jump
on you each other being melter through
still got 24 trip via my die soon
Oh 4650 okay I love this little like my
teammate is like awesome oh I got that
enchanted beam again one sec can I go to
the block pass away still blocked that
Jen again and then I gotta wait till
this thing opens up I'm like a chess pot
it takes blood its course in my mouth
that's disgusting oh here it is okay
it's a battle
The Scream bat I think is like okay you
hear Rock crumbling this is okay here we
go
the boss bat lair let's do this the
beefy bodyguard bat look at it it's
disgusting it's got the Gladys forearms
jeez he's doing a lot of damage
whoo all right I'm going to die I want
to die okay wait I need to heal I need
to heal crap no the campground the
campground rest in my tent
come on okay now back to the boss bat
slack Achilles stretch again again again
kill him kill him
how many bodyguards this guy got man and
oh the boss bat here we go the
two-headed bat who runs the battle
despite constant arguments with himself
which lethally easily before black eyes
oh my God look at him he gets a jump on
my toe fangs into each of my jugglers on
each neck oh my god that's horrible
critical hit though oh my god I gotta
get them again I gotta get them again I
beat them I got the damn snakes back and
I got the bat can belt okay perfect
I did it okay let me check my equipment
real quick let me see what that bad skin
belt is equipment yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't do anything what does the
continuum transfunctioner do okay and
enough of that enough of that let's get
out of here and seaside town the counts
of loving I did it guys
Oh cops map map we got word that sure
the knob problems who normally keep
themselves up planning a major military
action against he's not dad that's
horrible go deep into the knob and nip
this problem in the bud by neutralizing
the Goblin King there's a secret
entrance the car not knowing how to read
it you need to figure out the Crypt it
they find the entrance and I can't did I
find an encryption key see here Miska
lanius yeah a tie a tie is that okay to
map one hand encryption together do two
things first you distilled the map and
figure out the back entrance as a second
as you wish and a third hand so you can
enjoy a tasty glass of ice-cold lemonade
oh my god you memorise location of the
door then eat both to map any encryption
key no reason why it just seems cool
okay I think it to the nearby Plains
okay find some way to infiltrate the
throne room you are neither a guard with
cake nor one of my harem growls oh my
god you just beat me Jesus and I got a
kitchen get some cake
oh Jesus I'm like dying
Oh nah blocking first a lap here we go
oh great
I like to die yeah I'm like dead okay
let me heal out let me heal up rest of
my time come on I stop rest stop come on
okay lavatory I'm back kills good I lost
what the heck how I die so quick
okay 151 oh my god this guy does so much
damage 34 every time okay I gotta get
better weapons I guess then all right
wow this is crazy okay and we see we're
gonna buy something Market Square any
melee weapons must require 35 I'm not
there yet I have to meet staff right now
I think maybe I should just get more
armor how do I get more muscle so
trainer
I'll be back here client istic let me
just check out my client at work and
Marcia tile
with it oh these are like other games
now thank you and jobs board
Oh guys your armor there's memory that
made Smith Medicine Show those weights
birthday OH
I am the lead Smith I'm very busy
and I think I know what that is general
store mr. Saur I was here to donate okay
um
where's the place where I can once I was
trash real quick I need like train you
know now ordered what do I train again I
need like more muscular
not the clan district is it I think it's
going to rights out the tracks yeah here
we go here we go the Brotherhood of
SmackDown I think that's where it is the
trainer I don't want this
I just need somebody to like get my epic
weapon yet load a smackdown
there's a turtle tamer with smack teria
I get that
I guess I could get this oh just crackle
hit okay well I want to try one of these
super things
we generate when I spray a bunch for
each gallon of fury
oh it's passive hell yeah okay legs this
one do now
oh man these are like passive stuff what
the heck okay I might need this trust
Mac pass it
no blood we're out
have an ID
sleep for an entire adventure that's
what I need
what's audacity of the otter I'm going
to need that 42 the muskox hell yeah
lunch Mac
okay let's go fight this guy
thrust back oh did I beat them
yeah okay not great okay this is going
to be just like a painful fight than I
guess can't really do much about it you
know what the heck I thought it's
supposed to do the rest up
Oh guys got careless guy she says why'd
you guys look so strong 20 more armor
something
hmm
not doing too hot these days not doing
too hot okay let's do this one
search the misspelled cemetery for the
tomb of the unknown seal clubber yeah
here lies hey there I'm quite great
there we go Oh God okay avenge I again
I'm killing a smart skeleton zombie
disgusting
net good good attack this guy you know
like a cat can I beat the grave robber
okay what's next what's next
he hit my ash exam Bay I don't
misspelled it as AB may okay smart
skeleton I think we're just going to
beat a whole bunch of these here we go
here we go okay turning on a cemetery
path even tried yet a tombstone with two
crossed clubs grave the door
okay - riddle - how defens hobble
hamstrung eyes binded by cloth the blood
is frozen our ancient enemy for always
an error fighting for freedom from the
spell it sounds very oh Jesus
let me kill this mob me
come on attack again kill the scale of
ten come on
a ghoul okay
attack again with a skeleton it's on
yeah that's all I could say I had to fan
off because I don't want to like affect
the sound you know microphone I want to
Michael picking it up she says tell me
where I gotta kill them
come on what smart school what's a link
Oh
kcon kept gone grave-robber
man you guys are really killing me here
there's just a lot of okay the lick I'm
fighting so many schools and skeleton
yeah cool ears cool ears
Oh sob mags up may that yeah I got come
on
can man and a great probably shovel do I
get it to show me this you see what the
stuff I picked up does sonar in a
biscuit
um equipment three to six right now
seven to 14
what is that
weird okay well I guess I'm going back I
should keep fighting until I guess I get
to it then all this sin could be a while
it only goes as fast as my internet goes
you know I wish I could fight faster but
I can skeleton them and it carries on
babe a wonder would take a percentage
like every time you go it gives you a
percentage that you would come across
like a quest so I'm fighting for a while
right third give you muscle anyhow I
mean it doesn't hurt the key one
fighting because I get the muscle up I
must get going up and my house is going
up about 54 cool egg please damage okay
am I missing something here oh what's
going on solve the riddle the tomb
oh great the freezing Northland water
nope
board up here where you go you have to
fight me the announcer clever
now in the fight okay Oh
Shawn's hammer okay here we go
ancient stone hammer whose three trials
okay yes is the third one it's a
pressure plate each I'm swap with the
same weight a seal clubbing club but do
the trick estimating career I got to go
to the guild
Harry gout the avatar uh-oh the silk
lever here we go okay we can go back to
here go back to the cemetery go to the
on that tomb
check your pack switch okay
let me see what the bridge or camera
does though 5 to 10 my good muscles plus
10 my god okay good the guild better
beber beber beber beber beber okay I got
your weapon
I got your weapon Greg nur hmm with
return to full strength you do it by
recovering a bottle of ancient shield
blood okay
disgusting last one bottle was stolen by
the clown Lord huh
he's all buzzed out Jesus Jesus all
right this is a clarify
shake a clown I can't kill that clown
that whiskey how it's pretty weak
actually lemon in a box all these things
are like weird clown toys I get a lemon
hips Phuket damage acid squirting flower
scary clown I got a long skinny balloon
I love skinny balloon bugbear in the box
the disease in a box that's disgusting
in a box okay I got clown skin that's
pretty gross unless looks just like
cover mics and make myself into a clown
find bezel okay here it is
push the nose of course out
okay I got to fight a little bit so I
can get my health back up at 19
okay 24 24 come on 29 35 okay let's go
be something I have cream ask
hat powers 30 chef hat do
where's this dough
okay
okay where do you know yeah
um okay miss galini's
jesus there's so much stuff i have right
now what is that
clowns can
okay let's see bloom
it's symbols I thought there was like a
clown nose thing
I don't know what the heck to do here I
got to get that nose I guess right
oh just up like a clown okay I got
clowns good okay okay let's take one sec
ah normal let me just State this real
quick okay equipped cloud pants a cleft
equipped anything else do I
as you gotta get that to work Oh
can't do anything in there okay now I
think you were doing it
come on get to the door push the mouse
Oh
okay what am I missing
I had this on Oh
claps can
maybe I happen now I just needed that
water pink let's say Oh
he killed me
tripping a clown
what's bottle goofballs now
kitchen Bank and it was smart school
consumables consumables do I not have
all the equipment that is
Oh need a clown nose
maybe I just got that does you get that
okay I got the clown I was on let's say
now let's say person knows what the heck
I got disease
I don't think I have anything else it's
like not a clown
I think I just need to keep on fighting
until I get like suppling got a skinny
balloon scary clown I got a skinny Belen
I had a lemon let me do two lemon ashes
cording flower yeah I got that
clowns can bottle of gin
how do I put on the skin
we're going to put the clown skin with
long skinny below
okay come by
what have there's bad scam or is the
cloud scam
what do pants can in that way
okay well anyways so am I missing
something now 59 long skinny balloon
maybe I take off the stuff that isn't
clown stuff so like unequip this
okay
what do you sketch strong good
Oh bloody clown pants did I get that
yeah
Jesus
and when I climb that come on come on
50 she says what's going on here
attack depression s oh my god
I'm missing something okay is there a
sound like a help thing podcast go and
read it yeah
okay locations
nearby planes here's the funhouse fine
half son has okay
how do I get there do I do it what
Techtron acid
okay so I let her accept the keep on
fighting
I need how do I come more items faster
though a bugbear bun guard what is that
oh so I actually make stuff she says
okay here we go story times klonoff city
is
get crafted crafted clouds can with the
shark it what the hell
and I know how to get to the guy where
is it
I need more okay
clown skin with the pants kit with their
shirt cat you want to skill necessary
[ __ ]
muscles 15 have the muscle power 60
three skinny balloons
I need a blue sword recipe Jesus when I
get the blown sword
but I need three of these
I hate to pick two things
okay when used Oh idle craft if you use
it
- familiar
you just see how good skies real quick
where is a
blowing okay
what's the easter-egg alone
all attributes plus five okay that may
spoon shield does not provide clarity
eighty is three through lune helmet
advocate quality yes so use to okay
equipment blood helmet let's do it
oh I'm sorry let's do it come on
where are you alright yeah bugbear bond
guard what the heck is that
you
push the nose baby yes out ooh I killed
them okay I got sit of still seal blood
see okay
form the guild I got a thousand meet my
god
okay join hammer to still till blood the
hammer of sliding okay this is good this
is good
Wow this is dope okay the trainer prime
the pump in does real quick pass it
pulverize
and okay let's you get this weapon as
though nine to 18
whoa what's one age what hand it yeah
so can I do wheeled weight
and how many can I make that shield I
like to buck I need a shield just do
hmm
let me do the funhouse a little bit more
just get some more of these balloons
come on out eight symbol on seven eight
some balloons Wow why don't I think so
high 283 now
okay I got one balloon so I got three
how you get one more now thank you
come on my motherland
come on brah come on brah brah brah when
I'm sweating in here
crapola 13 by their bun guard big bass
drum what thing is that though
right
come on a tiny doubloon clouds can now
thank you
four three two one
all right well about anyways hope this
was an OK episode for you I know it's a
little confusing but thank y'all for
watching thank ya